Bienvenidos al nivel 1 de ecuaciones lineales.
Así que pues vamos a empezar.
La primera ecuación que me quiero tomar
es la siguiente,
"5x"... y tengo un 5 un poco gordo, pero ahorita cambio la pluma... "5x" igual a 20.
¿Y cómo resolvemos esta ecuación lineal?
Bueno, tal vez en un principio no te parezca
tan familiar esto, sin embargo, tener esta
ecuación es exactamente lo mismo que pensar en 5 por algo, 5 por signo de interrogación, igual a 20.
Siempre que tengamos un número al lado de
una variable lo que estamos pensando es que
este número está multiplicando a mi variable.
Esto es por convención, un número al lado
de una variable, se están multiplicando.
Pero bueno, lo que queremos aquí conocer
es a la "x" o en su dado caso a este signo
de interrogación, es decir,
¿qué número si los multiplico por 5 me da 20?
Y bueno, seguramente tú me puedes decir que
esto es muy sencillo, 5 por 4 es igual a 20.
Ahora bien, toma en cuenta que puede ser cualquier
número multiplicando a "x", por lo tanto
vamos a resolverlo de una manera sistemática,
aunque en esta ocasión ya sepamos el resultado
vamos a ver cómo se resuelve.
Si yo tengo "5x" igual a 20 y ya tengo una
pluma mucho más delgada, "5x" igual a 20,
lo que voy a hacer en el primer procedimiento
es dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre 5,
este lado de la ecuación entre 5 y este lado de la ecuación entre 5 y 5 entre 5 se van, me queda 1,
por lo tanto del lado izquierdo me queda "x" y del otro lado me queda 20 entre 5,
lo cual es 4, "x" es igual a 4.
Ahora bien, también hay otra forma de resolverlo
y déjame copiar aquí la ecuación original,
"5x" igual a 20.
La otra forma de resolverlo es multiplicando
ambos lados de esta ecuación por 1/5,
1/5 por el lado izquierdo de la ecuación y 1/5
por el lado derecho de la ecuación,
recuerda que lo que tengo que hacer de
un lado de la ecuación,
lo tengo que hacer del otro lado de la ecuación.
Si tú estas familiarizado con la multiplicación de quebrados, te vas a dar cuenta que 1/5 por 5,
es lo mismo que 1, son recíprocos y por
lo tanto me va a quedar que "x"
es igual a 20 por 1/5, lo cual es 4.
Al final es lo mismo, lo que estamos haciendo
es dividiendo entre 5 que también es lo mismo
que multiplicar por 1/5.
Pero bueno, vamos a ver un siguiente ejercicio
y déjame borrar la pantalla.
Entonces vamos a trabajar con la siguiente
ecuación lineal, -3 entre 4, -3/4, que multiplica a "x",
esto lo voy hacer a 10 sobre 13, a 10/13.
Y bueno, ¿cómo resuelvo esta ecuación lineal?
Si te das cuenta es muy parecida a la ecuación
lineal que teníamos hace rato, tenemos un
número multiplicando una variable, -3/4 está
multiplicando la variable "x", por lo tanto,
para que podamos resolver esta ecuación lineal,
lo que necesitamos hacer es cancelar este -3/4
para que así me quede la "x" despejada.
Y bueno, ya que me estoy fijando en este -3/4,
me pregunto,
¿cómo puede pasar del otro lado de la ecuación?
o dicho de otra manera, ¿cómo puedo cancelarlo?
Y siguiendo la misma lógica que vimos hace
rato, lo que voy a hacer es multiplicarlo
por su inverso multiplicativo, si tú hace
un poco de memoria te vas a dar cuenta que
el recíproco de -3/4 es 4/3 negativo, porque
date cuenta, si multiplico a -4/3 por -3/4,
esto es lo mismo que 1.
Y bueno, fíjate que aquí estoy poniendo
un puntito en medio de estos dos números,
este punto significa "por" y es que las convenciones
de matemáticas, sobretodo cuando estaban
hablando de álgebra, se dieron cuenta que
no era nada factible seguir utilizando la
x como "por", pues si no se confundiría la
variable "x" con la operación "por"...
pero bueno, recuerda que lo que estoy haciendo de un lado de la ecuación,
lo tengo que hacer del otro lado de la ecuación y también de lado derecho voy a multiplicar por -4/3.
Entonces -4/3 por -3/4 esto es lo mismo que
1, 1 que multiplica a "x", me queda "x",
mientras que del otro lado de la ecuación me queda
10 por -4 es -40, 13 por 3 es 39,
recuerda cómo se multiplican las fracciones.
¡Y ya está!
me quedó que "x" es igual a -40/39, esto
no se puede simplificar, sin embargo podemos
pasar a escribirlo como una fracción mixta,
es decir, voy a sacar los enteros,
que en este caso es 1 entero,
me quedaría -1 entero 1/39...
-1 entero 1/39... sin embargo, en lo personal yo prefiero verlo como -40/39,
prefiero utilizar este tipo de
quebrados.
Y bueno, ahora que ya tenemos la respuesta,
una de las cosas buenas de tener ecuaciones
es que podemos hacer la comprobación de que
realmente llegamos al resultado correcto,
es decir, lo que voy a hacer es sustituir
a "x" por -40/39, lo cual yo digo que es el
resultado y voy a ver si en efecto me da 10/13.
Y me queda -3/4 que multiplica a -40/39, esto tiene que ser igual a 10/13, es justo lo que yo quiero ver.
Y bueno, de este lado tengo una multiplicación
de fracciones, así que hay que multiplicar
al numerador por el numerador y el denominador
por el denominador, y me queda, 3 por -40,
3 por -40 es lo mismo que -120...
-120...
y de hecho, mejor déjame verlo de la siguiente
manera, porque podemos empezar a simplificarlo
desde acá arriba, si te das cuenta, aquí
tengo un 4 y aquí tengo un 40,
¿qué pasa si yo saco cuarta tanto de arriba como abajo? abajo me queda 1
y arriba me queda 40 entre 4 lo cual es 10, y ya está mucho más fácil, 3 por -10 es lo mismo que -30,
de hecho menos por menos me da más, 3 por 10 es 30 y después me quedaría 1 por 39, 1 por 39 es 39.
¿Y apoco 30/39 es lo mismo que 10/13?
Pues sí, si yo saco tercera arriba y abajo,
voy a obtener 10/13, ¿te das cuenta?
Que es justo a lo que yo quería llegar, a 10/13.
Y ya con esto ya tengo el resultado, acabo
que comprobar que "x" igual a -40/39
es mi respuesta de este segundo ejercicio.
Así es que vamos al último ejercicio y me queda -5/6 de "x", esto quiero que sea igual a -7/8.
Y si lo quieres intentar por ti mismo, es
el momento justo para que pares el video
y no veas la solución, porque justo ahorita
voy a empezar con la solución.
Y bueno, la idea es exactamente la misma que
en el ejercicio pasado, voy a multiplicar
por el recíproco de ambos lados de esta ecuación
y el recíproco de -5/6 es -6/5,
entonces voy a multiplicar -6/5 por esto
y -6/5 por el lado derecho.
Y -6/5 que multiplica a -5/6 se va, esto es
1, entonces del lado izquierdo me queda "x",
mientras que del lado derecho me queda 7/8 por -6/5.
Aquí puedo simplificar un poco porque -6 tiene mitad que es -3 y 8 también tiene mitad que es 4,
por lo tanto voy a simplificar un poco y me queda 7 por -3 lo cual es -21 y después 4 por 5, 4 por 5 es 20.
Mi resultado es -21/20.
Y pues bueno, ya está, así que vamos a comprobarlo.
Entonces voy a sustituir el valor de "x" y
me queda, -5/6 por -21/20, esto es igual a...
y primero voy a sacar aquí quinta y me queda
1 arriba y 4 abajo, aquí voy a sacar tercer
y me queda 2 y 7 y entonces me va a quedar,
menos por menos más, 1 por 7 es 7
y después 2 por 4 = 8, es justo lo que yo quería,
este resultado de aquí.
Así que ya está, ya tenemos el nivel 1 de
ecuaciones lineales.
No te pierdas la continuación en el siguiente video.